[Music]
what was the strangest
uh classroom assignment school
assignment you guys ever got
strange we had to walk around look poor
and report
what that was like oh my goodness oh
[ __ ] yeah
that's dark yeah oh look poor i messed
up
look we'll like like look broke as [ __ ]
and then walk around and i'm like that's
my childhood like what
i gotta do a [ __ ] essay on that and
then report
like the looks that you got or like what
kind of how you were treated at the
store when you wanted to buy stuff
like a social experiment yeah yeah
interesting i'm like
i don't know what were the parameters
for looking for
good kill maybe it was just what we
thought was poor what so what did you do
did you do anything differently or you
just
saved yourself nice she calls you poor
oh he's the one you keep mentioning oh
no no you didn't wanted to turn it
he did say he did say he was gonna just
you wanna know the truth huh
i pretended because i didn't wanna
[ __ ] do the assignment so i just
wrote the essay
i turned it in that's how you win that's
the truth or is that the lie
huh i'm just kidding yeah i got an a so
i
had like to take home silkworms i
remember i feel like everyone did that
you took them silk worms
oh yeah for elementary school hours at
school i took it home
in in the shoebox and it was really
gnarly we were just like still with us
at dinner
they're so soft i think maybe third yeah
it would just be chilling
at the the dinner table did our neighbor
i got a dinner table
and they eat the leaves so cool yeah
very cool silkworms i didn't do that i
remember our classroom had
had caterpillars and we saw a transform
was it
oh no we have silkworms they make little
balls right
like the cocoon balls yeah the little
the silk or the silk stuff
web looking things it wasn't uh well my
school wasn't rich
you all had butterflies we had it but we
didn't take that
and
[Laughter]
massive ant farms like this big right
and they have like
masks as well it's a mansion to them
it's like this big right no it's not our
yard is a mansion not a [ __ ]
enclosure
oh free the ants freely justice you
gotta watch
ant farm youtubers like they [ __ ] go
in and they have
whole ass crazy it's like a luxury
apartment complex for the ants
i have an ant farm and a sea anemone
see an
seaweed aquarium and an at farm in
animal crossing
oh my gosh
as a hamster anti-rex fossils i have
that too
no more i was so excited i was like
and then i heard in animal crossing and
i have a ufo so we kept getting more and
more invested and she kept going yes
yeah i'm closer i'm closer what a team
in animal crossing i have so many things
in animals
i have three girlfriends on gta
hey what are their names uh oh
brett
bread bread and bread all right animal
crossing aside and gta side in
pittsburgh
a mother is very upset about her
seven-year-old seven-year-old daughter's
uh classroom assignment and this
was the assignment that she received
and you guys i'm excited what you think
so this is the assignment that she
screenshotted because she was so angry
your creepy underwear wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait a picture of your
creepy underwear
here huh or just tell us about it what
the [ __ ]
[ __ ] initial reactions [ __ ] off
oh she's just says if you can upload a
picture of your creepy underwear if not
can you model it what does it look like
how does it
act wow the picture file must be on your
device it's like technical [ __ ]
wait how does that what grade yeah what
grade uh
seven year old oh no
it's like oh so so it's a skid mark they
want to see and i'll take a picture of
my [ __ ] [ __ ] on the that's not okay
that is so wrong as a parent you take a
picture of your own skid mark and send
it back no no no no if i was a kid
at seven and he told me a creepy
underwear they're like oh they must know
about my skid marks so then i'll take a
picture of the skidmark because that's
pretty [ __ ] crazy underwear right and
then i'll send it i thought it was like
a
typo i'm like what could what else could
be underwear is creepy underwear like a
character in like a children's book or
something
like captain underpants yeah here's the
thing it this was on october 23rd was it
like a halloween thing because it was
due november 6th
and then was it like it was like in
terms of like creepy underwear in terms
like if you had one with ghosts on it or
goblins oh that's
under child underwear oh i'm just
wondering what the [ __ ]
no it's not okay we're trying to side
with the cream
okay i'm trying to figure out if like
this person thought they were being
innocent but i'm like
i don't know it's so not interesting and
underwear is never innocent
what does it look like what does it act
like how does it act
what does that mean what does that mean
right it's like oh it creeps up in your
butt
like is that what happened oh that's
pretty creepy oh and the kids are like
oh i get a wedgie
and i don't know what that was is that
seventh grade or is that seven seven
year old no that's right
seven-year-olds like i don't even think
a seven-year-old could understand
explaining a wedgie right like i know
what a wedgie is wait was that third
grade
no second first second second grade
yeah this is weird that's when you're
picking your [ __ ] wedgie in front of
people not even giving a [ __ ]
you don't even give a [ __ ] so you just
go with it you're like oh [ __ ] teacher
wants to see your creepy underwear yeah
at second grade so did they get in
trouble the teacher get drunk all right
so
just to answer your questions from
deducing you guys are actually
on par with what actually happened so
anthony you said that were they reading
some sort of uh
book yes was it halloween themed
yes and so this was the book that they
were reading right the [ __ ] line
though
creepo this is the book they were
reading called creepy pair of underwear
so cute and it's actually apparently a
really amazing book i actually went on
to amazon and read reviews on the book
oh they said you bought the book oh no
no i did not uh but
i read it twice over this book is this
book the problem or like you know what
what the what the hell happened
the problem still the teacher didn't
understand tonally i think
creepy underwear and assigning kids to
pic take pictures of their own underwear
is creepy
and i think that's as far as it really
goes oh
oh so are they taking a blank underwear
and drawing stuff on it and no
they're actual underwear okay that is
not
yeah it's not cute because yeah the
teacher oh no wait but it's like
distance learning oh uh no they're going
to school and then the teacher could
have given them going
on site oh this video yeah here's here's
a video of the mom talking this is the
news reporting cutter out yet i'm upset
about it
i don't want my daughter even engaged in
anything that had to do with uploading
anything
personal to the internet we were reading
and i grabbed the
laptop and just it just threw me off
from there
i was so angry i took pictures of it
honestly it's like very disturbing
hell yeah and i don't want anyone else's
children to ever have to go through this
i'm more bothered that
myself as well as other parents whose
children see this they have to explain
to their kids how
important it is not to do this it makes
me uncomfortable for my child to be in
that school because i don't know who
else felt like this was okay
right is the teacher a male or a female
just curious uh they didn't explain they
didn't actually reveal the identity
i could tell you they're an idiot yep
for sure doesn't matter
what gender they were they're [ __ ]
dumb it was the librarian so
the librarian was reading this
particular book it was hard
or like oh like something scary and and
they were trying to be on theme with a
book to have kids
talk about which makes sense yeah which
makes sense for most people
yeah give them like an outline of an
underwear then like a piece of fries
but either way white underwear like why
do we go do hats it's like
it feels kind of grooming a little bit
you know what i mean it does draw your
own
creepy underwear and then upload it how
about i still think it's just weird in
general underwear doesn't have to be no
no no drawing
drawing yeah like that let's write the
book who the [ __ ] is this author right
that's what we're [ __ ]
words by aaron reynolds pictured by
peter brown
pitchforks people yes aaron no i gotta
read the book
to see what's going on
i read the synopsis for the thorough
analysis of this time it's like
i don't want to get to the point where
now underwear is like so taboo and then
it's like you grow up with shame about
underwear right it's more so just the
invasiveness
of it yeah it's not like assignment
really it's just the human decency i
guess
i'm talking about the book just the fact
that why choose
underwear no no like like it's just
because we're talking about underwear
here it shouldn't be uncomfortable
so i want to read the book and then see
what that's
of course taking a picture of a kid's
underwear is drawing the line from now
like a story to like reality but like i
think the book itself
doesn't seem bad just because it doesn't
seem that item of clothing
like captain underpants right it's not
perverted book is about a a little bunny
who is trying to transition from kid
underwear to
grown up underwear so it sounds like
diapers to to actual underwear or
whatever
but then in this book it glows green and
it scares them
scares them it scares them i can't [ __ ]
in this anymore yeah
i don't want to transition transition
into this so the book was about in uh
coming of age coming of age and then
overcoming your fears yeah
do you remember the moment when you
change you were changing and all your
friends had boxer briefs or boxers and
you had the tidy whities and you're just
like
wait a minute that was yeah that was my
situation
with like thongs i feel like i was late
to the game with thongs i think it was
like 14. is that earlier you had granny
panties on and
i had the grannies honey i had the long
johns i feel like i was about the same
age
maybe 14 yeah i guess that's normal then
okay maybe i was on time i was trying to
see all of them like damn
am i doing something wrong here dude
still like thong's at 14 as a parent i'm
like that's too young yeah well yeah now
looking back i mean listen the [ __ ] we
did when we were 14 like
no not okay you know like not okay we
were
really eager to grow up yeah children
oh also back then it was like the style
to show them right on your hips
you all the way to like suspenders yeah
like that bull rat on
like bikini is aaliyah's fault huh only
amir
hey spears britney spears aliyah just
had like she would show like the aliyah
would wear like the calvin klein briefs
and like to show the band no she had
like some rhinestone ones oh
girl or boy i've been watching you that
one
one of my favorite movies of all time
yeah but she did do the
the baggy pants with the box right right
fairfax yeah she did do that one too but
she she was like a fashionista
[ __ ] icon mm-hmm she definitely was
but this teacher is dumb
teacher i mean i guess it serves as a
lesson right like parents are now forced
to explain to their kids why they
shouldn't be uploading pictures of the
underwear
it was a test for the parents deep
yeah but now the librarian's gonna get
fired
[Laughter]
so let's say let's say creepy pair of
underwears in your class syllabus that
you have to go over with your students
what's the activity that you do
the piece of paper underwear right i
guess right away
but also like why is it what can we just
pick another book
right true that book sounds good though
if you're scared of changing from diaper
to underwear
but then like what if it was like bra
what if it was like a creepy broly or
like ultra long
freshman thong
cars that's cool bars
[Music]
you